years ago when I was a much smaller
human but a pretty giant nerd I spent
many evenings at my desk ring miniature
armies with which to do battle nicely I
could do that both physically while
collecting Warhammer and virtually when
playing the total war games but this
year those two worlds came crashing
together in total war war hammer and
when creative assembly the developers
behind the total war franchise asked me
if I wants to go behind the scenes to
see exactly what goes into making a
monster I jump to the chance with the
wood elves joining the ranks of total
war CA sent us over our very own tree
man which I spent the best part of two
days building and painting for our
studio visit once done I jumped on a
train and headed down to creative
Assembly's horsham de studio in the
Southeast of England to see what goes
into the making of our monster so over
the next 50 minutes i'll be going behind
the scenes to visit the talented
designers creating the concept art
chatting to model as animators and even
checking out how exactly you motion
capture a giant tree person
[Music]
from tabletop to gameplay this is the
making of a monster so we're starting
the day talking to rich I understand
you're in charge of all the new cool
content that gets added to the game
after release so we brought in our tree
man so once you decided what race and
what you're gonna come into the game
what's what's the first step to assemble
a team you like right that's a tree man
ties so we look through the army books
we see especially what's been in the
eighth edition and then we pick off we
pick our laws and we pick our heroes so
like I said we we make sure that we go
for something that's different from one
to another so after you've decided what
you're gonna put into the game your
relationship with games workshop how
much wiggle room to they give you cuz I
via Slee you've got the model but that's
very different to what ends up in the
game what what's a gray area between
those two things well that's the nice
thing that gray area really allows us to
expand out you know our ideas to bring
those things to life to make them really
cool and exciting so if you take the
tree men and their strangle roots for
example which are the kind of the
whipping lashing out attacks you know
there's a small passage written in the
book about that but it doesn't really go
into too much detail than and you know
it will say it's a strength verse and a
tech value that so we get to play around
with those ideas maybe you want to make
it like an indie style you know bullwhip
and lashing out or something about
ripping under the ground and encasing
somebody so that's that gray area again
where we're getting to play around with
it and bring these guys to life in a
vibrant and exciting way that gray area
is where the many artists designers and
developers really get to bring a little
model to life but one of the first
people who get their hands on our tree
man is concept artist Theo
[Music]
so in the concept art department now
talking to Theo what made you start
what's your inspiration for getting this
on the page you have access to the
models do you use the law so yeah
straight away we go to the miniatures
look at the law what the story is
there's so much artwork that built up
through the history of its workshop and
then extrapolate what's really good for
our game because our games obviously an
RTS its top down so it has got specific
look sitting needs to be here too and
work with what were the biggest
challenges when it came to elves and
treatment inherently is the fact that
they are quite complex and tree like
we've got to really make them feel alive
and a bit more where would a tree have a
joint where I would exactly yeah or
obviously all its special abilities and
trying to bring them forth within within
its design as well how can it a deer to
that with in-game signs when they're all
complete why do they go then you've got
it all down the page what's the next
step earn next stages and send them off
to the modelers this is Johann trend
character artist and modeler
extraordinaire who turns Theo's concept
art into the textures and models that
give our monsters in life so do you use
how close as you stick the concept out
what kind of inspiration do you draw
from to actually bring the detail and
character to life um you know it's
obviously Theo putting a lot of detail
into his concept as well as like games
workshop like the these D scoffs
themselves I think pressure the tremont
scope for for the would I was like is
probably one of the better ones I think
for for you know for the what else and
yeah like it's really got tons of
personality like they've done a really
good job of just making it like you know
giving essentially like a walking tree
like in a lot of personality and giving
a bit of like an alien feel to it which
was really cool and how much do your own
personal kind of tastes and twisty get
to add into this model oh definitely
yeah we you know we try to sneak in a
few things here and there like you know
I'm a massive overall massive nerds here
right you know like Marvel anime all
that stuff we kind of know subtle subtle
hints here and there like you know like
a little bit of bit of mecca's ah you
know like you know this is some echoes
and like you know Gundams and
and gurren lagann sort of with over the
stomach you know the stomach face yeah
sort of it's not all it's nice to start
looking for faces in the stomach area
right now are you telling me yeah yeah
pretty much it's just once you want to
see you can't unsee it kind of things
would you preferred you for making
humans or is monster something you can
really get creative with I think if we
personally it's like monsters for sure
like is this pretty much you know just
sort of satisfies my 10 year old self
you know it's just like creating also
like the making basically the fiercest
angriest meanest characters you can sort
of put them on the field like that's
that's kind of what is I really enjoy
like I mean everyone else here does like
we all go to our specialties and yeah
but I just I just love like that the
uglier the better Oz leavin me know the
better once the model is suitably ugly
the creation is given a skeleton and a
simplified version that is sent over to
the motion capture team a process that I
didn't expect took place in an old
warehouse on an industrial state around
the outskirts of horsham but it's here
in this shabby oversized shed that the
magic of mocap happens so we're here
with Pete Clapperton motion capture
manager show us around this is your this
is your Playhouse your studio what can
you tell me about is this is a 11 meter
by 10 meter volume which is quite
sizeable for mocap studio especially
internal one in the game studio we have
a 48 camera vicon system setup optical
system basically you get someone in a
suit you put 53 markers on them which is
our defaults out and they were
reflective for the infrared light that
you can you can see around in here and
that basically picks up all the markers
and and it identifies where they are
within the volume and we attached a
skeleton to those those little points
and then you get your character movement
and you can attach that to whatever
character you want I can see you've got
some peculiar props over here as part of
your creative process working I bought
is this for you got heaven mystic a
trampoline I was that like a gymnastic
um where is a gymnastic horse but really
to us it's a real horse they even has an
H on one side and they on the other for
the head and the other end
and.and yeah trampolines and her jumping
about we do a lot of deaths like you
know explosive deaths and that sort of
thing they bounce on there and off you
go if you see someone in the game get
hit by a cannonball that's someone who's
been in a studio jumping off a
trampoline and fall into a matter how
we're gonna look at the game in the same
way I'm guessing for the total war
hammer it's been a bit different for you
guys because if you mentioned before you
worked on Shogun yeah so as I know
they're all humans in Shogun but now
we're talking about monsters how would
you go about doing motion capture for
something that I mean isn't a human
could be a goblin or a big tree man how
do you how do you capture that it's a
little full of it is to do with
performance you've got to have it in
your mind what you're doing because a
lot of stuff that's by people you know
two legs it's generally sort of kind of
it's just a human character but they're
creatures and they don't move like
humans so you have to get people to
perform in the right way it's actually
one of the reasons why we get the anime
is to do a lot of the stuff themselves
because they have in their mind what
they want it to look like so they're
very good at reproducing that in in
their own way I don't one more question
for you can I have a go course you can
[Music]
after an hour or so of being covered in
balls and working up a sweat pretend to
be a giant living tree the next step
stores head back into the warmth of the
main studio again to hand over to an
animator who ensures that the
performance is just the right kind of
wooden now we've been to the motion
capture studio where does the motion
capture come in for for your role so
normally go to the mocap suit its first
of all just throw some ideas by the end
of the day we'll have mocap data and we
literally put that in the game the
following day and we just see where the
things are working so the case for the
treatment because of its nature because
it's really as a tree it's not kind of a
living kind of character or something
about symmetry a spirit that's kind of
control and the actual tree so not the
movement always getting the motion
capture wasn't working quite straight
away off the bat for things like
monsters like a tree man how do you kind
of animate a sense of presence its its
size snatcher its mass what do you need
to do to so you know how human moves but
is this kind of guess work in your
seizure medication we always kind of
these reference so there's cyclus
chromium reference films you know you go
for like Lord the ring so they call the
kind of the tree characters in there as
well so use those kind of references
anything from YouTube kind of act
ourselves I'm just an also kind of
imagination how we think that looks
believable the key thing if we believe
it works that way and all kind of things
we kind of solved on that idea finally
how many animations this guy actually
have I would say probably prob about 70
odds it's a lot of man-hours to animate
otras yeah exactly so called all the
roots are so many different joints one
of things we want to do when he punched
the ground that the roots will come from
the ground there to remake in essence
you know when we kind of animating all
these different creatures we really want
to get those kind of personality they
look different from other characters we
don't want this this giant to be like oh
it's like another kind of big creature
really want to give it that kind of
personality kind of identifiers or
that's unique while a sense of presence
and person has been keying creating a
monster the point is mute if our
creation doesn't have the right sound to
match its stature
so for the final step in the process I
spoke to senior sound designer Byron
Bullock about what a treatment sounds
like so now you've got the everything
from one of the teams what's your first
step how do you start the sound creating
the sound for for the treatment in the
game is a quite a big process for for
the audio team there's quite a lot of
people involved and kind of I'll work as
a sound designer with the dialogue guys
to create a kind of process I suppose
for the sound so we wanted to sound
wooden kind of hollow and extremely
large all sorts of vocalizations like it
screams its attacks footsteps when it
falls all those kind of sounds that make
up the rest of it give it some life life
I suppose right so what goes into the
Foley then obviously you mentioned is
quite a lot of parts of that the
movement the attack animations what goes
into making the monster sound like a
monster well with the treeman we
actually had to go out and record real
tree felling sounds so we went out as a
team and it was about four of us that
went out with a professional we didn't
actually chop the trees down but we went
and recorded the sound of large oak
trees falling and cracking and so you
can imagine this out of an oak tree kind
of falling that kind of org and that
kind of sound and those sounds make up
the actual vocalizations and also the
the movement of the tree man pan you
have an interesting tree man story and
it comes to recording some of the audio
well it's a strange one because there's
lots and lots of sounds that make up the
tree mantle is there there's the actual
real sounds of trees falling but there's
also sounds of elephants pitch down and
reversed there's my voice making weird
vocal sounds as sound designers you have
to be able to make strange noises so
yeah we made just lots of weird noises
then it all comes together in the
editing to create something that kind of
think should sound like that hopefully
we fool people
having met many the teams involved in
creating something like this I really
got a sense of the passion these guys
feel for their creations and just how
much they love doing it these are teams
that gel together coherently and have
done so for the best part of 20 years as
both a warhammer fan and the total war
fan it's been absolutely fascinating to
come behind the scene today and see what
exactly goes into making these tiny
miniatures it's the giant monsters we
see on screen if you've enjoyed this
behind-the-scenes look make sure you hit
that like button subscribe to gamespot
and we'll see you next time
[Music]